in today's video these people will be
hiding and me and Chris will be
searching yeah
and Chandler car are hiding with the
randoms you know to give us a cool
perspective I'm gonna win I'm a random
and whoever we find last wins $10,000 in
cold hard cash Chris start the game ah
okay win here okay guys guys boy Jedi
get on me on me right here and now
they're all hiding they're going to
their spot hey everybody
whoever I find last gets $10,000 in cash
pick a good hiding spot you guys have
five minutes and by five minutes I mean
until I get bored and since there's so
many people hiding we have these
snowballs that blow up stuff to make it
easier on us you put a whole hole in the
roof even have ultra snowballs oh my
gosh why these destroy buildings we're
gonna refrain from ultra snowballs for
the moment there's a house right here do
you see what this house is Team Carl HQ
so look first of all let me show you the
first hiding spot in here I think it
feel like it's pretty good good a smile
I made it before we started so it's not
cheating where do I hide
5,000 we're starting everybody go it's
happening we're starting so Chris our
main objective is we have to kill Carl
so we're the team Carl hidden bunker I
have two previous winners with me let's
check all the hope I found somebody over
here tonight can I throw a snowball at
him Judith Oh something just tells me
someone's over here oh yeah somebody's
underneath here watch this Oh over here
in the tree you get that I'll get Joe
Road oh there's two people in the tree
pay me and pancakes how about pay you
and nothing oh there's three people over
here boom you go damn baby not fake
well not alive either ha ha you're just
blowing holes into the sides of
buildings turn what's up here oh yes oh
we just deleted them now be careful he
throw these cuz you're creating new
hiding spots because someone could hide
it here now that's the name of the game
baby
what was that breach breach who's over
here
oh who is that jump
Oh random amount if you pick right you
live if he jumps five times I'll let him
live nope
I see someone Oh Chandler you guys got
to make your journey over here I think
I'm in a really good Oh somebody gave me
up oh my god you'll eat him oh no Taylor
Joyner Cole Chandler I'm so sorry who
snitched on me no I saw your scene head
poking up Bob Chris as much as I'd love
to torture Chandler I spotted another
person in here alpha deaths are now near
channel you wanna help us find people Oh
chilly
you probably saw a bunch of people are
you're hiding tell us where Carl is Carl
I have a feeling you're in Victor
yes oh my gosh dang it you found me Oh
nope I didn't find you but I found
radioactive bean three oh I see a
nametag stuball stuball nametag name tag
oh alright Carl go back to your stupid
Pole but we will find you and we won't
kill you I think we break out our secret
weapon if you know what I'm saying dodge
Chandler was in this building and
Chandler doesn't like to be alone
which means Chris we got to bring out
the nuke nuke it I'm getting a cinematic
shot this might cause radioactive
fallout
dramatic music dum dum and bought a boom
bottom thing I'm gonna throw the new kid
dead center now oh that oh okay we call
it the building oh do you see knew it oh
oh he survived he survived three nukes
oh he's on the run sucks to be you
should have got mad at Chandler for
staying in the same places you got um
daddy I see you nametag I see your
nametag oh right here right here a ding
ding ding on me on me go go go operation
Delta 69er going up front where they
going it's gonna get up got him you know
where Carl is Carl's in the coral house
oh my God why have we not checked the
coral house yet we're missing the level
of this building right here you think
Carl's in it yes Chris you know what you
gotta do you destroyed my house were you
there yes why would you be in the house
you built before we started recording
that's the first place because it wasn't
the first place to check think about it
how many people have we killed so far
you guys just killed me and two winners
big scene boy Jedi in one snowball who
Carl yes don't find some people okay can
somebody give me a snowball first
identify three people oh okay oh I found
somebody look at this guy
oh no look at this guy Jimmy let's have
a word with him stop running or you will
be neutralized alright he is not obey he
must be neutralized hey I'm just gonna
give him a chance guys if you're
competing an event and I ask you to stop
running you need to just predict that
that's what I'm saying
even though you can't hear me you need
to read
mine and understand his gestures hey
Jimmy you said I'm bad at finding people
cuz I just found two people guys I think
we need to get more organized there's
four of us here let's go to my
headquarters all right so let's split up
in a team borrow Chandler I want you
guys to destroy people you guys have to
prove you're worthy of snowballs I
already found two people I need a
snowball oh you found people over here
oh wait Chris you're too Chandler you
know who that people with cute anime
skins live oh I found someone in here I
found a cute panda Chris but pandas are
going instinct Oh Chris our snowballs
messed up our subscribe sign do what the
sign says and hit that subscribe button
right now I found somebody he was hiding
in her hole he's running guys never try
to run away from me that's just what it
to you boy yeah just don't run away
uh-oh Jimmy oh and he led me to somebody
else what a jerk
now I'll give both of you
[Music]
can you make the parkour good job here's
your prize
shirt shirt sooo that's it leave them
there will kill them last what is right
here shirts ooh okay ouch
I feel like I'm telling them to crouch
we want them to win I think they're
helping you Chris get away get away
don't let him know you're here let's
find him yes yeah let's go : they put
jerk suit in a box and then left before
the map started I made a hiding spot in
the map and I want to see if anybody
went into it right in here yes we caught
one instead of us killing you guys I'm
gonna keep you guys in here I think we
should rejoin the cold Chandler in him
so what did you guys do with Jerr - oh
we killed him we destroyed them oh we
thought you guys were building a secret
hiding spot for him we were and then we
were like wait we should just kill him
here come back to main Col Alpha Delta
over out okay we will in like two
minutes I'm not gonna kill you guys but
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna leave you
here with a bunch of cats
Jimmy hates the noise that the cats make
so if he finds you because of that but
no well okay good luck comrades Oh Jimmy
behind you what is this how did he get
oh dude that's a good spot hi sorry but
you must die let me make a lava bit down
here here let's let him kill himself
jump into the lava and I will respect
you whoa
wah-wah-wah
he will be missed anyways let's go
slaughter more people all right oh I
spotted someone Carl let's see if he
passed the checklist okay does he have a
cute anime skin no does he have merch on
No
then he must die oh my I found somebody
go to him and tell him give him a sign
that says stay still stand on purple
block she's standing on it she had so
much to live for
there's three people in purple building
or heat three people Chandler I found
two of them right here here they are I
think it's ultra purple oh it's time we
go crazy
I want this map level Jimmy I found two
and I'm sorry to rat them out but come
with us well they were in my perfect
hiding spot that I made before I started
you want to know something Carl
I don't care kill them all no level the
map boys oh you must see you must see
why do I still see building standing
boom gazenga poppy we kapowie I'm making
it rain fire I still don't have a
snowball here don't hey come here
Carlton sir gently Oh two people I got
two people boom boom ah I'm just gonna
hit this one to death anyway I say war
doggy above gently haha
die die yeah Jim will say hey you would
say hey who say hey oh one on right here
right here
the heaves in the wall stuck Oh Oh bye
buddy dude there's nothing left on this
map
[Music]
[Applause]
Chris look at this nobody killer just
look at how well she survived
she's completely naked by the way I'm
gonna pretend NEC I don't even want it
hey there's no way for her to climb up
here cuz the building's been leveled oh
she's just chillin falling all the way
to the ground I guess she didn't want
ten grand everyone count out live when
you kill someone under 10 people
remaining chop top oh six more like
snowball hahahaha eight people remain
people I found someone zoffie hey buddy
oh you found Sarathi where are you oh I
found a silly boy what are we at what
number did you say seven oh he's on the
run Zachary is on the run
why you bullying me alright so six
remain six remain did you say 600 kala I
found him at the same time there's three
Oh Alan gamer the guy that won ten grand
in this video shop mr. B's the guy
that's in every video this guy hasn't
won 10 grand and doesn't have a cool
skin so he dies you know what I want
them to duel to the death
Oh Oh he did not hesitate you won the
right to live you have 20 seconds to hi
before we kill you
come on his damn shot mr. Bies we have
to go easier it's fair for people
remaining hey I made a house for the
next victim I told him I won't kill him
and then I'm gonna blatantly kill him
right Carl
you how many people are left now how
many three alright shot mr. beast and
two other people saw no one whoa wait
anime it's a boy Chris I'm a skilled 1
to 10 how cute is that skin that's like
a tick tockia voice skin
he's an AE boy we're looking for anime
cuteness he's more cutesy clearly only
the smartest person here is allowed to
kill her so there we go I think you
accidentally must click them two people
remain and one of them is shot mr. beast
I found one I found the final guy Karl
are you just GP to them like hell why do
you keep finding someone every 5 seconds
because I've just been running around
the edges grows in the grass stop
running if you run I'm gonna kill you
wait you should I trap them ok now we
could look at him like a like a pet 5
hex I kind of feel bad there's you and
one other person left and yeah jailor I
don't know how to say that he's not
getting the money can you say to him you
don't get the money you lost I'm sorry
shot mr. B's doesn't know this yet but
he just won $10,000 shot mr. beast are
you in the cold one here there's one
other person and we found you first
so you came in second place okay so you
just won $10,000 seriously yeah you
literally just won 10 grand so how old
are you 13 can you let your parents know
that you as a 13 year old kid are about
to get $10,000 okay yeah all right thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
you hit that subscribe button here's
another video it's gonna disappear 3
seconds thank you for coming out bye